-So you were mayor of
San Antonio.
You were Secretary of Housing.
-I was.
-And now you are
running for President.
It is a crowded field.
I don't need to tell you.
You maybe don't have as much
name recognition
as some of the candidates,
and on top of that all,
people often confuse you
with your twin.
-You're really encouraging m
tonight, Seth.
You're really encouraging me
[ Laughter ]
-Well, on top of
everything else --
-Feel better about myself
already.
-Well, you have a twin brother
who's a congressman.
-I do.
-And so, I imagine that,
you know, just like any twin
that probably gets in the way of
name recognition as well.
-That's true.
You know, about two months ago
he grew a beard so that people
could tell us apart.
And then he realized
that it looked so bad
that it wasn't worth it, and h
shaved like four weeks later
He likes to go around
telling people
that the way to tell us apar
is that I'm one minute
uglier than he is.
-That's very nice.
[ Laughter ]
You had been mayor
when you got tapped by
the Obama administration.
And President Obama called you
to ask you to be
the Secretary of Housing.
What was that like to get
a phone call like that?
-He did. In fact, I remember
that it was on April 16, 2014.
And I remember because
I had just driven through
the drive-through at
Panda Express when he called me.
[ Laughter ]
And you know how on your phone
it says unknown or blocked call.
It said, "private."
So for all of you,
if you ever get a phone call
that says, "private,"
answer the phone.
[ Laughter ]
Hopefully I'll be the one
on the other end of the line
-Yeah, there you go.
Did you tell him when he calle
that you had just gotten
Panda Express?
-No, no.
I think I pretended like I was
behind my mayoral office desk.
Like, "Oh, I'm still working
at 9:00 at night."
-You're, like, yelling at people
who aren't there.
Like, "I'll deal with that
later!"
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You had a background
in housing.
That was one of the reason
that he tapped you.
That was a policy issue
that you had spent years on.
Obviously we referenced it
earlier in the show.
Ben Carson, obviously
a very gifted neurosurgeon
but that is different
than housing.
How -- What is it like to have
had that position and look a
someone who doesn't seem to have
the same outlook on it?
-Well, I mean, his hearing
yesterday was like watchin
a slow-motion train wreck
until they got to the Oreo part.
And then it was like, "Oh, man."
What do you say about that
I was telling some folks
yesterday, that it was --
this was one of
the classic cases of,
"It would be funny
if it weren't so sad."
-Well, that I think the sad part
is again -- because, you know,
obviously different parties ar
going to have different outlooks
on how to handle issues
in this country.
But it seems as though
his position is just disdain
for the idea of the government
providing housing
to those who need it.
-Yeah, I mean, what I disagree
with him on is that he seems
to think that if you're poor
that there's something wrong
with you.
And I completely reject that
You know,
HUD serves a lot of people
who are trying their best.
A lot of folks
who are working hard.
And just because you're poor
doesn't mean that
something's wrong with you
-You know, I think we've noticed
it amongst many of
the candidates who have
thrown their hat in the ring
Trying to find a signature
issue, trying to find a thin
to let people know how you
might be different than others
Immigration seems to be what
you are staking as your issue.
Obviously, you come from
a border state.
What about immigration is
different as far as
how you see it?
-Well, I think in Texas, you
know, we know that the peopl
that are trying to
come to our border,
who are fleeing
desperate circumstances,
are not a national-securit
threat.
They're not somehow evil.
They're here because they want
a better life for themselves
and for their little children.
And they're like immigrant
who have come to this countr
over the generations
from different places.
And that this president,
from the very beginning
of his campaign,
has demonized them and used them
as a scapegoat,
and on their backs
is basically trying
to get re-elected in 2020.
And so I just wanted to put ou
an immigration plan
that represents
the complete opposite
of what this president doe
and says, "Look, we can have
a border that's secure.
But we can be compassionat
instead of cruel."
[ Applause ]
-I think everyone -- or I should
say, many people are critica
of the Trump administration'
policy
in regards to immigration.
But obviously, you know,
Barack Obama --
you know, he deported a record
number of people,
particularly early
in his presidency.
How do you distinguish yoursel
not just from what
President Trump did,
but what President Obama,
an administration
you worked for, did?
-Yeah, well, I mean,
I think what happened in
the Obama administration is that
the Obama administration,
over the years got stronger,
got better on that issue
of immigration, right?
I mean, in 2012,
you had DACA that was released
And then in 2014 they did DAPA
which was supposed to
cover the parents.
The number of
deportations of people
actually went down
through those years.
And the other lesson that
think we learned
from that administration was
that when we have the chance -
when we have
the Democratic majority,
because I think that on
January 20, 2021, at 12:01 p.m.,
we're going to have
a Democratic president,
a Democratic House,
and a Democratic Senate.
[ Applause ]
What we learned is that
from the 2009, 2010 experience
is don't wait on
immigration reform.
We're not gonna wait this time
We're gonna push
sensible immigration reform.
-You know, you mentioned
an ideal outcome for yoursel
would, of course, be, you know
the presidency and both houses
You know, one of the thing
that might actually seem lik
the hardest right now
is the Senate.
And, you know, there are jus
fewer houses -- fewer race
that seem likely to flip.
And some of the criticism of
this incredibly talented field
of people, of which you're
a part of running for president,
is that they could maybe
serve the party
better by running for Senate
that someone like you
or someone like Beto O'Rourk
might have a better chance o
winning a Senate seat in Texas
than the presidency.
Like, how do you speak for that?
-Well, I think Beto would be
a great Senate candidate.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
That's a good answer.
-No, there are great folks
that are running in Texas
that are already
starting to line up.
My brother was
thinking about running,
and then he decided not to
-Well, they saw that beard
and they were like, "I'm not
gonna vote for that guy."
[ Laughter ]
Has it been strange to --
You know, it seems as though
every day someone else
jumps in the race.
I think, you know,
by whatever count,
you know, 21, 22, 23 people.
At this point,
do you kind of want to say
"Hey, that's enough"?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I would have said
it was enough after I announced.
You know?
After I got in, that's it.
But yeah, we got 23 people now
Bill de Blasio was the last on
to get in a few days ago.
And, you know, I just talked t
John Lithgow on his way out.
He pointed out that we hav
enough for both the offens
and the defense
of a football team.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And we have one extra.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Well, that's good, becaus
one of you is gonna get hurt
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's probably true.
-Yeah.
Hey, keep your health up.
Keep your energy up.
-I will.
-And thanks so much for being.
I really appreciate it.
-Thanks a lot.
-Julián Castro, everybody.